Olga Bochner this year's price must have
been the most anticipated price in the
Nobel Prizes history so why did we have
to wait for more than an hour
for the press conference oh you have to
understand that this the decision about
the cries is taking from the very same
day when it is not so there was a
discussion and there should be a
discussion otherwise if the price is so
anticipated and no one in the Academy
even have to come to the decision
meeting and today there were a number of
people there and there was a very good
discussion and we landed on the surprise
because in ours
and these are two scientists Laden Vic's
who actually wrote the theory in the 60s
1964 so then I had to wait even longer
for the price I say well you know there
is a lot of theories out there and I'm
gonna experimental it myself so you have
to understand that my attitude church
theorist is okay so there's a fear there
a lot of theories out there there's a
lot of theories out there but in the end
it's the interplay between experiment
and theory which decides what nature has
chosen as the grand scheme of things and
so it took 15 years for the prediction
they made in 1964 to turn out to come
true and the thing which makes the prize
interesting right now you asking why 50
years is because of this observation of
a new particle at CERN where the
properties expected them by the theory
so this is why sometimes I have to wait
50 years and sometimes the theory may
turn out to not be true and this is this
so-called Higgs particle many people
have heard about it what why was it so
hard to get to discovery
well there are several things one thing
is that the theory predicted that there
ought to be a particle it could tell us
the properties of this particle so how
it interacted with other particles with
matter particles and force carrier
particles but it couldn't tell us what
the mass of this particle was and so we
didn't know where to look and so
actually for the past 50 years this
particle has been looked for at every
accelerator in existence
so it has been looked forward the IOR it
has been looking for the SPS at CERN at
the left Collider at the Tevatron
this is this was an ongoing harness so
from other properties one could try to
narrow the range of mass and what did so
both of them at lab and the Tevatron so
in the end we knew more or less that if
it existed it had to be bad and then the
LHC came in it is the most powerful
accelerator in existence could produce
enough energy to make this happen and so
we found the particle well the particle
in itself is not as important as the
theory which is represents so the theory
tells us why we exist because as I said
in my talk this is a philosophical
question then again but maybe tells us
why we don't float away like the photo
and we all know that we are massive we
know that we consist of atoms and the
atoms have atomic nucleus protons and
electrons and neutrons this is what we
consist of but according to their
theories which existed before the
mechanism was proposed all these
particles ought to have the massless and
we know that unfortunately we are
massive from a more massive run of
people but definitely not massless so
there was something wrong and the theory
proposed their solution and this is
where the theory is important and the
particles is important as a
manifestation of
so all coordinates get the masses from
the Higgs field the Higgs field theory
and where does this Higgs particle exist
is it here around us where is it
well I have to modify this a little bit
all particles that we consist of get
mass from the Higgs particle they're
particles which do not seem to interact
with the Higgs particle named nu chinos
and so the standard model is not
completely complete that it is probably
only a low-energy approximation of
something larger which also explains the
mass of the neutrinos which also
explains the dark matter for the moment
we don't know but electrons and protons
and neutrons the quartz inside them get
masked by interaction interaction with
the heat so one way of looking at it is
to imagine that the Higgs field is
something which pervades all the
universe it's everywhere it's here in
the room it's out in in the black space
it's everywhere and so every particle
moves through this field and it's forced
to will interact with the Higgs
particles in that winkles
moss all the time now all the time
and we don't see we don't feel mean we
are born like that right so you wouldn't
we wouldn't feel the fear but where does
this feel then the particle come from
well this is something that we actually
don't know I mean this must have
happened in the Big Bang somehow that
this is how our universe is constructed
that there is this field it is possible
that this field was part of the
inflation process would blow up the
universe from a very tiny size to what
we have today we also don't know that we
don't know there's only one Higgs field
or maybe there's more Higgs field so
there's still mysteries to solve
if this Higgs particle is so crucial to
the whole universe and the discovery was
so hard to make why didn't the people
who made the discovery get in the world
price well this is as you know it's a
very difficult question for me to answer
because we are no it not at liberty to
divulge their discussions which take
place inside the Nobel Committee or
inside in DD Academy when the decision
is made but let me just tell you the
decision on the prize is based on
primarily the test that the will of
Alfred Nobel on the nominations which we
received this very year and then we of
course take into account the prestige
and tradition of the prize now weighing
all these things together we came up up
with
the proposal of this year's prize and
now for the rest of the internal
discussion will have to wait for two
years
your spoke to just Wangler one of the
lorentz but not to Peter leaks will you
try to call him today yes we're going to
try to call him later today and actually
I think we left a message of his
recorder that we have not that the
Academy that have been trying to call
him but the Stockholm has been trying to
call him and we hope that he'll respond
the rumor has it that he has gone into
hiding for the rest of the week in
anticipation that you know since this
price was so anticipated he knew that in
either case if he gets it there will be
press storm if he doesn't get it there
will also be a press storm so it felt
like it was better to go into hiding the
Higgs particle has been said to be the
last piece of the standard model puzzle
for elementary particle physics is
particle physics over no circulation
well the standard model is complete so
far so good but as I already told you
there's still unsolved
things one is the neutrinos they somehow
don't fit completely into the standard
model they do have mass but apparently
they're not getting their mass through
interactions with leaves
there's also the question why the Higgs
is so light maybe there are more more
Higgs particle maybe this is just one of
them and are more to be found
so today the belief is that the standard
model is a low-energy approximation of a
more complete theory and this whole
complete theory is what particle physics
is after now so there are various
speculations supersymmetry may be a
possible extension of the standard model
those are people speaking of extra
dimensions so that our four-dimensional
world
is just what we perceive of a larger 10
dimensional worlds and the other
dimensions are just tiny rolled-up and
we don't see them so there are many
speculations out there and like with the
Higgs you know experiment will
eventually show which theory is the
right one